yeah yeah yeah oh that oh yeah yeah yeah
know that that's the ice princess I
think her name was subbu this week I'm
gonna be at Amarillo Texas
this Friday August 10th McAllen Texas
August 11 Lubbock Texas August 24th
Lorado Tech is sick August 25th Brea
California August 30th through September
2nd Labor Day we can check out Filippis
WorldCom's last tour for all upcoming
shows and ticket information this week
on the podcast we have Lana Turner she
is the wife of the late comedian Ralphie
May
she's also been a guest in the past and
she'll be on later on and we will sure
seen their song mayonnaise
what's up fool we talked about it last
week but it's Trani coming she's calling
you right now oh wait what are you gonna
say you didn't get to talk about it last
time what if you want to bring that oh
that we were - Wow
what's up listeners on Facebook we went
to just go check out our lucha Vavoom oh
yeah awesome
a lot of guys out there looking a lot of
guys wrestlers out there with me and
they had a burlesque
I got a badass burlesque dancer in that
one girl it's good that's in a pole a
floating floating pole I've never seen
not supported by the ceiling block that
way to the microphone right here you do
it on speaker yeah up to you Mike what
kind of Johnny rocky right now what to
be here
what's up well were you at dawn I think
you're supposed to be on the podcast
today dope bro it's been noon for the
last three and a half years bro
oh it's been twelve what's wrong with
you one time what are you talking about
lost your mind first of all somebody
buys a podcast you are immediately at
one time you know wait a year and then
ask later hey what's on the podcast
there you go
I'll put it Nick girl what I asked you
bro units what time right don't turn the
[ __ ] Johnny they're gonna be here
people he's too busy getting another
Hickey was so cool that city it'll be
the three of us God first of all man if
you're asking if somebody advise you to
go somewhere be on a podcast you should
have immediately what you have either
never told what time well but what's
he's standing right there when I told
you we're having Lana you guys are at
the driveway the end of the driveway
[Laughter]
from Johnny handsome to
johnny-come-lately
by somebody somewhere but I don't want
to go I don't even therefore what's
happening you are like are you gonna go
do that thing yeah bro yeah and then do
this I know I know what that is but they
want to get that car always right now oh
yeah you paid no mind for a lot of
people a lot of people are fooled by
Philippe and I think that he's just
flying by the seat of his pants and
isn't paying attention to stuff but he
knows calculator food
so what's up fool what were we laughing
Jacksonville Jacksonville Florida
we're in Jacksonville Florida man it was
humid as a [ __ ] George showed up
rose George George cousin from Gaza
George plugged in ski soda oh [ __ ] dude
this is my homie right here down from
the project's Joe Shabalala bro
who's that for yo ello bro ellos for
flats Oh shade for flats I guess yeah
he's cool brother I grew up with that
guy Werner summer camp is [ __ ] dude this
guy I saw it one time like I would never
like he was cool with me right but I
knew they'd [ __ ] fight but you kind
of like this little eco fight but he can
fight you get mad now I saw here one
time I was coming home and I was coming
home and there was this big black dude
in him and ready to go at it where they
go at it and they put a corner at his
shoulder like none knocked on my
shoulder or whatever in the final star
back in the days like a slap in the face
- right and the first like that would
knock it down
this girl knock it down but if like the
person knocks it down so dude this black
dude I think they was junior or Lords
more I don't know so that fool will at
this - Joelle oh my god
but on the corner a ninja wanna just
punched our full in the face for those
inside the gym dude like oh they leave
it outside and I stay a while I get it
let it good there to play basketball
today and I [ __ ] left
but I don't want to be next which a
while oh I don't know a little listen he
brought do you remember that I think
maybe not no I think we saw the last
time figured the podcast so good to see
you well so what were you texting me
alright the memory zone he went to the
comedy zone before yeah Jacksonville
yeah let the play with a hotel room
right I don't okay is that the one hotel
okay yeah yeah yeah we're more than that
it's several times when you walk into
the lobby the comedy club is to the
right the lobby to the left and then
Gigi's eat at a restaurant buffet is
enough right haha I don't know that I've
experienced Gigi's Katie but if that 12
totally doing a comedy show instead of a
boat yeah cruise ship bro because you
can't get away from the half of the
people after the show do this I don't
want to see you having sex in a swimming
pool when I'm walking back to my hotel
room are a lot of people saying what's
up on Thursday from Saturday so do a lot
of people stay there yeah really it's
like a destination thing they've a lot
of stuff going on at those hotel though
they got a huge buffet they got a lounge
in a comedy club there's something else
right yeah bother me as well something
else though it's like a it's like a
high-end buffet though right lobster
crab legs
never missed you theater to be fine is
you gotta find out who [ __ ] to this way
yeah I was gonna say I don't remember
this this being a Dean is a nice
no you're gonna listen to the rest of
the show go to youtube.com slash ATC
okay / ATC my faith page my facebook
page personal oh okay you're going next
week you're the free food so tell me
when we didn't get free food
they act like they're never gonna get
free food again huh I was like what's
the big idea over here yeah four days to
get everything one day this guy had like
big old bats a Porter porterhouse steak
a prime rib in uh but he likes uh crab
legs crab legs and when you're used to
not being treated right on the road and
somebody offers you free food it doesn't
matter if it's a plate of fried crosnes
you're just like oh my god it's free I'm
not stupid
yeah it's the greatest we did a show in
our theme was Tucson Arizona and before
the show there was a buffet and a side
of the stage it was a good buffet man
they had good food there was a fake chef
right there slicing prime rib
that's yellow they had cake then then
people said don't watch his show I fell
asleep is that rascal no it was that up
to time we were there the comedy club
and was at the casino ah before they
were standing up there was like a coffee
shop on the side of the stage were so
food we got a lot of Turner right here
hello hello
so while Soho their soul dies that broke
he will have details
I was killer dude is the best show we
had so far I was packed yeah dude it was
it was a good asked her now did it get
you like people came right at 8:00
though dawg
as I hear that 7:45 goddamn I thought I
advertised
and then uh Marty showed up early did
you run a white t-shirt how about booth
yeah but he would do you as good dog
he was dude he let it out though it was
tight and uh it was me and Louise
Banuelos came he has a new number by the
way I'll send it to you thank you he's
my new name read that so you went up
there have any little jokes get back to
the podcast yes crazy you know his
impersonation of Louise sounds a little
bit like the Peter what's his name
Peter no one to know anything that might
be Murder by Death
Murder by Death with a change gay Peter
Sellers playing the Chinese guy the the
Chinese sort of detective like yeah like
that old Chinese detective I can't even
take his name but he has this accident
he's a lot like the way you do it but if
you look at him he looks like one of the
could be an old kung fu movie dog and
then I'm getting kicked their captain's
cousin was out from New York you just
stand up and we gave him a little guest
spot so he was cool he did good out
there
yeah grabbed it came out of and his
cousin uh what's his name Payton McCann
from Alaska was related Sarah Palin dog
that's his and all he did comedy yeah
yeah in his credit and then a hooter
went up did a little 10 minutes and then
might be more in no clothes that I was a
45 45 minutes yeah they're not talking
before the first rate huh no I do you
was good dog like he's getting is like
he lost [ __ ] to get a little sex a
little bit was sensitive people
which was all dude what Warsaw fool
big shut up to Willie Barcena his kids
get [ __ ] up together now Willie put up
up I only started because make up man
posted it up right mega man tag do you
wanna comment on the video come overi
Willie Barcena and he's like having a
beer and his two kids are having a beer
too bro uh-huh weird though right cuz
we're getting to that point in our lives
now we're kids we even we knew it like
20 years ago and you're like oh my god
you got a dolt yeah yeah the kids are
like in their 20s oh I know it's
tripping me up totally tripping and
we'll it goes hey are you guys date that
don't even have time to hang out with
your kids eh but I think you do have it
Abby your dog and then later on he
apologizes with another video broken
somebody will get it bad I guess the
video
uh-huh what do they say no it wasn't
really apologizing he's sorry if I
offended any of any of you deadbeats who
don't want to spend time with your
arrested basketball stars you know after
it one more beer there's gonna be the
wrestling request for real bro you want
to be into the mix and forever people he
owes out stuff to him and all the
community other stuff to him but that we
say here and then no idea what the [ __ ]
he's talking about I've never said
anything bad I know now shout out to the
Joe Rogan experience I was on the show
last wait
last Tuesday really for hours yeah for
hours I spoke for two minutes
I spoke till I was first hired uh it was
cool manage of him and I just rapping
about boxing and all kinda [ __ ] this guy
had one crazy line tell me how stoned
were you guys working out and then got
tired
hit a ball which were cut again it got
tired for you're tired i blood I would
have known about your back would I get
that for a pack of OG louis xiii healed
already
I was there by that one up
he did what he did light up a blunt yeah
before he got there oh okay after the
show we hung out for another thirty
minute playing pool ya know that we
invited it was cool a lot of people
listen man I got a lot of calls a lot
cars nobody called me a lot of food were
proud and I emailed me the emails from
people in Australia because you know how
I mentioned that there I got into comedy
because why I decided to comedy but
there know how to write jokes laughing
Perez so I went to the library and asked
librarian so a lot of libraries hit me
up oh hell yeah
librarians you know we're still here man
they're very funny people because we're
very quiet very quiet but we're really
really funny and have dirty dirty
Decimal System you mean the yeah yeah
we're talking about that big old deal
with the book I don't know how often
they update it but they use the Dewey
Decimal System in the computer now no I
don't know about the actual card catalog
no job to get rid of some cards now
somebody had a job man if you had a Java
the library bro that's not inside the
library
that's library with the guy out behind
the scenes when it's closed [ __ ] a good
ass job catalog library the library guy
behind the scenes yeah like the guy that
puts everything away
back again huh those were the [ __ ]
books go dude that's the kind of job
they talk to myself like oh he's an
idiot
he touched himself well bro when you
pray you talk at your stuff too you
[ __ ]
crazy I had a real give me do that I had
to put away yeah when I first met you I
mean you have to do all kinds of stuff
when you first moved to LA to just those
type of job bring up the best other
people don't man if they're like if
they're that comedian or you're gonna do
this or not because death that shit'll
funny is true is the worst parts of your
life that make you that's why we're all
so miserable roaches on this thing
yeah well the worst job you have I used
to [ __ ] this the worst job but the wall
no do the worst is just when we used to
clean out attics dude it'd be hot as
hell did just digging out insulation and
then like dude a couple fools falling
through the ceiling dude it's just like
he dude that somebody fell through the
ceiling yeah cuz you know you do have
information yeah sometimes you get a
little too comfortable you forget forget
about it if you have been doing that
long and they fall through and then full
get stuck and then like but Hussein was
a mad improviser one time I we were
getting out these bees at this at the
library at an Hacienda and we broke it
you like it was like a panel so we put
it all back together but it was still
cracked and then when we went to Home
Depot and we found this brown silicon
that matched it kind of like that crack
filler for women
but it would have cost us more to fix
that than it would the payment we're
gonna give for taking care of my girl
cleaned houses crappy job that's a
crappy job yeah if people are slobs oh
yeah actually there always was your
worst offal like I had a job dude man I
don't ever mention this for the great
Boyle he was here and he got jobs at the
Columbia Pictures or the you know at the
studios and no I guess under the sets'
just others our basement and right there
was all kind of pipe pipes there were
all plastic and some of them were metal
and they hired us to uh take out all the
pipes poo so they were gonna bring in
new ones and the first day we're
screwing them [ __ ] this [ __ ] thing
forever but they're like I started
talking to a lot of people that work
there right like the employees a real
employee and the people hired us so
what's gonna happen here after we get
rid of they're all like I said [ __ ] that
room demolish the whole room and putting
new pipes so what's gonna happen to the
piles right now the plastic was [ __ ]
that they're not throwing away the next
day after everybody man everybody put
down screws pick up hammers what are you
gonna [ __ ] everything up is gonna throw
it away or anyways so do we all picked
up hammers
instead of screwing out all the pipes
that they told her to [ __ ] that dude we
broke everything [ __ ] brains man
we're done in a week
idiots bro no more work after that no
more I could just took my time we're
like a bicep or Union style done yeah
you pay we were standing line and this
fat white dude who let Boss Hogg
Hollywood
you guy.you part of the lowest of the
totem pole there dude your pain with a
hundred dollar fifty a hundred fifty in
cash and they each room writing okay
this was 1990 bro I still good as money
though
so cash bro food with bloody fingers
through that buddy dog through the with
him with the [ __ ] was taped up finger
didn't go to a hospital grabbing that
money me clean ass had grabbing a
hundred fifty and grabbing $10 from to
others poor other guy because at when
I'm with a job gonna wet my beer a those
for losers bro there who who didn't have
[ __ ] to do but sell rocks and PCP all
day so I told her my name I know it's
like a great job man and once we food
have money every Friday the pipe I
drives so but but you gotta pay me $10
to I'll get you this job so I got every
day every Friday these pools for food to
give me $10 each
so that's all making $20 dollars for
what finder's fee writer sweet Fred job
just every Friday you could you text
those same people yeah why not just a
one-time fee you got a man for every
week you will be replaced given a cut
that was a good job that job last three
weeks but the best part was while they
were filming on rocky 4 and we saw rocky
every saucer purchased a loft or bed
really every bad by were that his whole
car was big floor fingerprinting hey
dude
now what do they used to work with you
said they used to always say that's what
she said well job was doubtful or Ebro
know those that was a crazy I redneck
that was living in Rosemead and that
fools fighting with a city because he
had two pigs dude to Vietnamese pigs
they were gonna let him keep it to his
Turkey every day [ __ ] [ __ ] so
therefore that we may put the form a
poster let's go around the whole city
leader leave itleave posters name save
the page full this blue had a yard that
was 2:30 to play to dirty dude he did he
had a big he collected old fire engines
so here like like like he'll see like an
old fire engine for the 30s that's our
self for change ease he'll just buy a
blood pocket in his yard I never fixed
it so here like already he had four fire
engines get an antique road show we get
him he had two pigs running around the
house bro hairy little fools dog know
why but why dogs like you one of the
contractors that like if you see the
mother contractor who's gonna have a
conversation with us again how about
more time yet having this job oh we have
one more day tools are gone dude we'll
have a conversation with other cars
trucks to hell over the building and
they'll find out how many days they have
like if they're gonna be gone next
weekend better get him now that means
that also he's gonna come back and get
their tool for them and forget other
tool was done but did Native American do
name bro are thing Ronnie Everage name
to John Redcorn
he was far they thought he was a date on
that food that's for maybe he drew that
for for he was smoking a cigarette was
too little pays at about a bro
holy to all kinds of two boxes Robbie
put beware
I was working for Western Electric
Western Electric was a company that was
that was higher during the times when
they were selling all the other other
phone companies the baby Bell baby bells
consolidating them into the bigger all
the Pacific under one Pacific so when
they were getting rid of all the phone
all the phones 18 teach are you coming
in because it would have cellphones they
saw the future so we were our job was to
go in there and slice slice phone lines
okay kill cables from people and Yankees
all day all day bro all [ __ ] they all
target thousands of miles of cable
tonight five four floors so we'll be in
there pulling cable are they so I met
this for Melrose at the Melrose AT&T
knew he was like his old crew they're a
bunch of doodoo didn't work dog plus
this fool or change smoker never seen a
chain smoker Lana I'll put a shade Grove
what are that chain smokers yeah right
turn it off and then the next we put a
brand new cigarette and light it with
the old cigarette you know the big
secret then you turn it off keep the
chain going and this back then you can
smoke in a [ __ ] green room bro
and then that fool say that's what she
said though these two women they were
chuckling about something downstairs and
we were up there right legal yeah
Giuliana I'm having a really hard time
getting up this morning that's what she
said farts bro little [ __ ] photo go
down because AC is up there so the AC is
hitting us
out so that fire will carry them that
[ __ ] AC will carry the part lovely
person I use oh yeah dude I forgot bad
though when they put that beware science
the city put the bow for co2 on man
it'll grab it bro put any connection a
whole toolbox if you don't got your name
it has anything [ __ ] magnet ah and so
you read Melrose working for the other
one and how do you how did you run into
I just he worked for Western Electric -
ok so they put it all all the lazy crews
together will be a leader like like I
guess bros me had white boys back there
and this other do that worked her him
and I will take a lunch a got a fat
stress joint dude I was smoking in his
party the whole time like I didn't even
know that back then that the Merle
Emperor was just right there I didn't
want to be a comedian if I would've
known bro I wasn't just wait for the
open mic and invited Oreo that food is
still tools for the [ __ ] improv it
was already dude he looks short short
redheaded old white dude big-ass beer
bunny bro little arms
hey I know so many Stan bro I hear blue
eyes and his mother his mother grew up
in Compton I'm sorry
back in the days and his mom every sad
everyday still went to leave flowers for
that fool really hell yeah she grew up
in the old days bro the old days when
you made a lunch for your [ __ ]
husband and you live a little note
[Music]
what's up fool a lot of tourney right
here
what you going about it so much how's
the kids sorry about Ralphie me yeah
that sucks
right oh yeah yeah that's yeah little
her daughter bros remember a little a
little August in April right probably
April man they're big they're nine and
ten now she's a party animal she should
get down and party I love when kids get
down a party later like this dancing
involved and I do when they start
dancing to it yeah yeah she was all
sweaty and she came up to me and she
said we have to go you're wiping her
face
sweaty yeah they had a blast her wedding
was beautiful it was a beautiful
beautiful day yeah that's how many years
has happened almost oh my god wow so
much has changed in four years I had no
idea I was at a wedding and that I'd su
not be married you were here on your
anniversary on the podcast the tenth
anniversary I think of your wedding and
I think there were already kind of hints
already of that thanks for enjoying so
well filed and then I didn't follow you
followed everybody thinks it was me it
was not me Felipe well I didn't know the
banner he filed twice so here's the
thing it's such a sad story like it was
very he was really sick you know he was
really saying he was struggling and I
went to Madison Wisconsin and he was
coming off of an early oxycodone
withdrawal and he wasn't in the right
state of mind I think it was before the
paper the knees I would say that
reporter you know when he had pulmonary
embolisms
at all it was everything oh he had that
before he had pneumonia and everything
oh yeah embolisms got over ten years ago
now so after that they took him off weed
cuz his lungs couldn't take weed but
they were like here's all this other
stuff
well he went back to weed but his lungs
you know we're never the same because
when you pass those clots through your
lungs it destroys them and he should
never have taken up we again but they
also you know that he got hooked on all
that other stuff so he did a couple of
stints in rehab it was a mess for seven
years he was in and out of hospitals and
rehabs eleven times in seven years while
we were still together and that last
time when I found the pills I didn't
know he was back on pills I should have
known because all the signs were there
but I I'm ignorant and I found them and
I was scared for myself and the kids
because he wasn't in his right mind that
we all know and that's him he's the
sweetheart but this was not him and so I
took the kids and we went home and that
week that followed he filed with people
that soon became his management they
weren't his management before isn't that
crazy
so he filed with attorneys he became his
manager no no filed with fir a friend
and those who became his manager that
person just did the paperwork for him no
he took him to the divorce attorney and
then became his manager Wow yeah so so
that was a big mess because I don't
think he had his best interest at hurt
so we Ralphie actually unfiled because I
was like why did you do that I was
devastating and then he refiled a little
bit later in secrecy he didn't tell me
he drew files but I'm a woman and I have
a sixth sense and I I I did a little
research and I found because the thing
about divorce is like there's this whole
who files first thing and there's all
this [ __ ] like it's like you're it's
all this legal stuff that should not
enter into a union between two people
who make kids and love each other but
anyways I found out about his filing and
then I filed in California because this
is where the kids and I and him were
living all those years even though we
had a second residency in Tennessee and
when that happened TMZ reported that I
filed for divorce because they look for
the filings here so I was only
responding to him and that's how
everybody thinks I filed for divorce
which I never would have I never would
have left him which in hindsight I
should have but I wouldn't have that's
crazy that Rafi would file for Chuck for
around the boys that messed up man when
I was [ __ ] coked
for three days I bought a [ __ ] stolen
car for somebody positive even know
didn't even think it might be I didn't
think well just out of the good deal
right paperwork and I say you the money
later but then I passed out and they did
for one of the buddy he was threatening
me and I said Matt you gotta do all that
you know I I we made a deal I signed the
paperwork I'm gonna use the money
because the word buddy you know but my
hello to you knows my Degla James you
know yeah I'm not gonna fight this guy
or you know or whatever it is you know
it's a mistake you know but I give the
money but the car was straight-up stolen
you didn't know for sure but I when you
told me you bought a car for five
hundred bucks cash the night before and
you had the title I was like wait a
minute I don't wear the title but it was
this Chinese man's name and this guy who
sold it to you was not Chinese but he
had the title for the car with the time
the guy might have had his title in the
car some people do yes some people do
that yeah you know those Buddhists the
Buddhist temple that's over we're his
oldest no I'm Boylston and like temple
there's a Buddhist temple right there
big Buddhist house well right up the
street is where this guy lived and he
might have been one of those guys and
just didn't really realize he's got a
fight to get his car back but it wasn't
that guy you were partying with wasn't
it please eternal yeah five hundred
bucks so what are you ever gonna see
again yeah so when he told me that I was
just like look you lost five hundred
bucks but you're gonna take this car
back this is hot so we because it had
his name on it and like nothing else and
no other information and then we found
his registration I think and then we
just ended up dropping the car like
you're so whacked out that you can do
the craziest things know yet just go
[ __ ] up this do that man what were the
problems we put that out we got he went
to jail for five years for assaulting
somebody yeah but that's crazy that you
were like roughly movin that out there
right no no no I mean he wasn't but
here's what's so crazy about all of this
it's all on kid not all of it but a lot
of it was recorded on camera because you
know we had started a documentary so
nine months prior almost a year prior
Rafi had wanted to get lap band surgery
and I was dead against it because he'd
already had two stomach surgeries he'd
had a steep stapling before I met him
and then after last comic he got gastric
bypass so when I met him you guys
remember he was 800 pounds Wow yeah and
then he got down when we got married he
was about four thirty and it was looking
like he was a party he was great was
that three no he was probably 454 30
somewhere in there cuz he had done the
gastric bypass and he was daddy knew the
good he was doing good and that's why I
told I never didn't believe in Ralphie's
ability to overcome his his issues with
but it's all substance abuse whether
it's food it just switches to different
things in your when that's addiction
right so like anyways so we when he said
he wanted to do the Lap Band I was I
told him at that time I said I don't
think are gonna be alive in two years if
we don't do something drastic so I'm
like we could put duct tape or we could
continue to cut your tummy up and he
wanted to do that man so in starting
that I got my friend do you know Kat
Reinhardt so she was the podcast with
you for a while she's amazing
sure though I don't follow him around
right she was one documenting you I saw
he walked in with her she's like little
punk
yeah weird the way
Tyler stone so what time I knew at the
Comedy Store
I was trying to throw a name but a lot
of comedians there last time I saw him
he came in and we're all hanging out in
the greenroom and joy was there and
meeting Rafi may went up and then he
took off from the store that might have
been yeah and she was having
yep so that's one of the last times a
little bit a little bit yeah uh-huh
yep so you guys know so Kat was filming
this like nine month window and what
happened during that nine months was I
kind of started to realize that things
were never gonna change he didn't
qualify for the LAT band and he was
supposed and I was kind of happy when he
didn't qualify for it cuz I was like
great now you get to do it on your own
the cameras on him the pressures there
we're gonna get this weight off you
finally and you're gonna be okay what
made him a bad candidate for it he'd had
two circles his other health no he'd had
two surgeries and I mean I think I don't
know I don't know I just don't think you
know it's it's not I don't care how much
you whittle away at somebody's stomach
it's not gonna be successful so you
can't because the real problem is that
it keeps coming back though excess of
his other issue it's a mental issue at
this point it's a it's it's not the
tummy that I mean the gastric bypass
restricted his appetite or whatever his
ability to eat enough but even with that
he when he passed he was 590 pounds so
he plumed at the end of his life over a
hundred pounds once I was out of his
life so yeah but but yeah we documented
it and which is crazy so we have I say
we I heard I'm in it I did not edit it I
did not shoot it Kat is responsible for
everything in it because I'm a subject
so I can't it would be irresponsible for
me to say I don't like this or I don't
like that so it's a really very neutral
presentation of what happened during
that time period and the second part
about that is that she also shot a lot
of his stand-up so she has this hour and
a half
movie documenting that year which is so
sad
funny moments but really sad and
beautiful and then all the stand-up that
we couldn't cuz you can only sprinkle a
little bit of a stand-up in the in the
documentary is what we're doing this
IndieGoGo for it's a try and raised the
funds
put together his last one-hour special
utilizing all the stand-up that didn't
get used in the documentary so that's
kind of where I've been doing the last
month is trying to raise more funds for
the IndieGoGo because everyone's like
you won't know that you're rich no he
didn't leave I'm rich broke because I
live in the I live in my house has broke
I live in my house I've been able to
keep the house and and I'm kid but the
kids yeah that one house was here no le
right I've kept that I'm able so far
knock on wood he there was 200 and like
88 dollars and 22 cents in his personal
account he died that's it yeah this is a
corporation or did he was he just
working by himself as he had a
corporation that had a little bit of
money left in it not much but that goes
into probate and his manager the guy
that I was saying has sued the estate
three times so that's cost a lot of
money in probate court because he keeps
suing me and he keeps like making it
really difficult to like let this man
pass and he was his manager for how long
from the time Ralphy left me so less
than two years yeah he's lovely
and so yeah we're just but anyway that's
all negative I don't focus on the
negative because there's so many
positive things to come out of like okay
obviously the worst possible thing of
all is Ralphie and I can't rough it was
on tour right would he pass he wouldn't
stop he was constantly working how they
worked him doing in Vegas I don't know
the last two years he was constantly in
that damn bus huh
even Jody remember yeah so down every
weekend yeah he couldn't he could you
know what though I saw I guess you know
when he passed I got his emails
everything there was an email from him
baking like he was like I want to I need
to quit the casino I need to have a
break to that dude that I was telling
about I just don't like this I trying to
forgive him too and think that he's a
sick man as well he's very sick but he's
like slow your roll big boy that's his
answer like here's Rafi who's like
literally dying
well yeah but Rafi got another residency
offer for South Point when Ralph and I
were still together I was like this is
the most amazing thing he could have
done just a few dates at South
point and for the COS south points you
guys know 1,200 seats South Point right
Harrah's 540 seats I think he had to
work twice as much to do an FIR and then
South Point draws in Vegas to the local
community Harrah's has to compete with
everything else on the set on the strip
so like they just basically made him
work five times as hard for the same
money it was crazy I was like but I
wasn't involved in that I was already
out and like he and I weren't even
talking at the end he was so mad at me
cuz I don't know you leave me he said
things like I don't know it's these are
the negative things because he would say
how he kept him from the kids or
whatever and I know I never did I never
did never never never did like well how
could he keep a man from his I don't
know how you keep somebody from their
kids like it was women office does
taking the oxy after the pulmonary
embolisms but it wasn't just oxy I mean
it was xanax percocet I don't like those
times when I would think man he must got
something to be a Twitter this land
aboard inland arguing for it you know
you didn't even know even me and as
coked out I was I was like you know I
want to say [ __ ] this guy I'm gonna
focus on much on this person I'm follow
unfollow block yeah that's what I do
somebody sends me something negative
just block it out of my life you know he
was Rafi's social sense a minute a man
I'm over here about I'll go [ __ ] him up
for you that way you already call the
cops
ya know man like it's true that he was
so such a sweetheart so to see him
oftentimes um like kind of just implode
on Twitter publicly and again I there
was only so much thing I couldn't do
anything at the end I like they have
done a lot of work on me because I think
that's all I can do I'm like was super
super codependent I still AM like I do
you are well when when Felipe was going
through his addiction it was you're a
codependent it's all a cycle right yeah
but what you said to is really what you
have to keep remembering what you said
earlier when you said that he was
becoming a different Ralphie not the
Ralphie that he really was you know the
sweet
dear Ralphie you know he was becoming
some something else and you do become
this other person unfollow but you have
to make the distinction as a person who
loves an addicted person you have to
separate in your mind this is the addict
and this is the person I love because
otherwise you're constantly trying to
save that addict because you think he's
gonna wise up and realize how much his
family loves him how much his kids mean
to him how much this is really what he
needs to get back to he won't ever
realize that once you know with that
other with the addiction going strong
you'll never realize that you don't give
a [ __ ] about anything else nothing else
and I know that and it took me a long
time to realize that you are two
different people it's like it's Jekyll
and Hyde it really is and it's mmm it's
hard to go through but you know that and
that's why I said I don't ever want to
see that person again you know because I
that person has no part in this
relationship and if it comes up again
that I have to go have to leave it
because it got to protect you
yeah because you you keep thinking that
other person's in there and I know he's
in there but he's not paying attention
right now you know like when you're when
you're loaded but it is like a
completely different person you know um
also I think you can tell me about this
because his anger deflected back on to
me yeah like as if I almost felt like if
for one minute it just bring any point
during the years that that you were to
your window that followed if he'd have
taken one ounce of personal
responsibility about anything whatever
it was it could have snow balled into a
sobriety but it never had a that if the
urge is going strong there's no personal
responsibility there's no I'm sorry for
this I feel bad about this until it all
the drugs are out all right oh right it
just oh like it your system has to be
clean to start to realize all that stuff
yeah because otherwise your brain is
still seeking out that hi and that's all
you care about when you're spiraling do
you feel like there's because there's
other people that come into your life
and around
support that right like when you've been
in the dark spots do you remember like
some of the people that were there for
you during those times that weren't like
dee dee are you able to decipher between
like somebody who's really there for you
and somebody who isn't well for for me
or my enemies would I'm like that yeah
yeah that's what I mean you think you
have a whole separate the thing is with
Philippe he compartmentalizes that so
those people he parties with uh-huh
during his his binges and he hasn't had
a binge firm it's been nine years now
oh wow the people he parties with during
those binges he doesn't want to see
their face when he's sober what is it
like when you see somebody from that
they won't he won't hang out people
think I get close to him we can hang out
and party and all the stuff after that
when he gets clean he doesn't want to
hear your voice hear your name you know
what's your face like Steve
jack-in-a-box in the afternoon cool a
total morning yeah my jack-in-the-box is
cool a white cat feels cooler in the
morning but at noon myself I'm driving
past but he's constantly because addicts
are also are manipulative and they can
they they say okay I know these people
will always lead me down to find the
drugs if I need it I know this person
I'm not going to call this person ever
again he's really sober but he's always
ready if I need it if I need the stuff
would you've been out of town you can
pick the person who appreciate if you go
through photos of like photos of me back
in the days I'm pretty sure like a
person who knows that I'm a drug that I
will pick out the right the person that
I parted with hit by the photos oh yeah
this gets it now never together never
there he's the guy yeah cuz they kind of
background
he was holding he was he was the guy
taking the photos won't take his coat
off together dressed up we're not
at school that one day that you're
hanging out with ugly-ass Bulldog that
huh little holes in his face dog oh
[ __ ] reptile dog like so sick so it's
amazing though nine years that gets so
hard for um I tried al-anon for a little
while I should go back but like I
learned that it's like maybe one in
seven gets sober it's really really hard
and also those na and AAA and those
things they have a really low track
record right he's like 25 percent
success rate maybe there's just not that
much success in I just think in general
the person has to be ready I I couldn't
do al-anon I tried but I have where it
loses me is when they ask for the higher
power I didn't have never been able to
find a higher power that I can I try
higher power the beating my higher power
for some people that's true yeah we
spent there was like this three-month
window where we I've gotten him into
rehab and I would have done anything to
get him so burger I mean at any point in
our marriage but that was an $80,000
three months and then we have 380
thousand dollars in one of these posh
not that much I wanna party yeah I wish
I had that money now no I mean yeah
we're so seriously I was crazy I can
sham because what are you gonna do it
like I had to the I just like I'm gonna
force him to do this and of course and
then he's staying out in this like sweet
house pad in Malibu and I'm like I
you're having a vacation and I'm like
going crazy
oh yeah yeah I went to that one he went
to one of those one of those yeah oh
there was Trump jr. yeah and that
doesn't work or andis three months no he
went to a month in Malibu and then like
another two months at this food and
fitness
rehab facility in Tennessee and Lizzie
Lohan
but you out they say [ __ ] to outreach
our rehab and Rob rich people so it's
the treatment can't be the same without
stupid I got treatment that works is
like hitting bottom
no it's like it's like sucking a dick in
in Skid Row
that's rehab having a whole family [ __ ]
on you it's the best we have everybody
leaves your ass but when you have money
you buy 80 G's to go to rehab bro Angwin
over here a bro no we're gonna [ __ ]
spill it all in one day
ya know it was it was a good time
probably yeah and at $80,000 but for
three months bro you have enough money
for somebody sneaked you impales the
employees you could buy out the employee
it doesn't work but the thing is you
were saying about them somebody written
all they're preying on the families
because I think it's at all levels of
people's amount to be families like
there was one family there that their
son was there and I don't think they
were a super rich family but they would
pay any and if if my child is I am gonna
take whatever measures I can I would saw
my house to get my kid sober and right
with it and you don't understand the
kids sitting there going as soon as I
get out of here
its back on and the family's desperate
they lose every desperate moment like
especially when you lay when you quit
doing anything like so for anything that
you're into they're not into drugs
you're failing to be supportive like you
come out or is it to finish asking on
fishing poles whatever man I wish that
story man I called chief Daryl gates his
[ __ ] snow [ __ ] racket dog a
[ __ ] crackhead
that's we came out and said that um that
my weekend weekend partier should go to
prison they're the ones again I'm people
like my son and people like me addicted
could we want a party all week these
guys only party Saturdays [ __ ] that work
on mine
so so exist that we can partner to get
more time than people who are addicted
he says he's so weird I never heard him
say that's so weird
yeah that's crazy yeah he's crazy he was
in the heat of the night he said that
too man
oh they are chibok yeah yeah he got his
son arrested and so did Michael no no
Martin Sheen's got Charlie Sheen
arrested that was the time he got clean
he got him out he got him clean because
he went to jail yeah I think it's
interesting like every like everyone in
our business we're so susceptible to it
cuz like you're saying our schedule and
everything's accessible like when I get
to go on the road now when I go I'm like
people put joints in one pocket like all
kinds of things are happening I can get
laid like and it's not it's not like
it's not like it was before I mean I was
going on the road with dragging my kids
across the country and now I'm like I
have no kids I have no responsibilities
and I'm just like jay-z the doorman's
none of the [ __ ] security guards
these clothes are discreet they stated
in spirit or not I've seen you buy weed
oh you want week or the night I want a
coke
you never asked for the name you give a
[ __ ] about who bought coke of you but
they give you the name like you never
asked I don't even need the WD I sure
bad giggle what diet pills they tell you
everything these guys don't give a [ __ ]
boy crazy my four was hot like have
money culture yeah this this is not an
idle time though - when there's when
there's nothing to do and you're stuck
in Jacksonville Florida
all week and you're kind of like a rock
star for you in Jacksonville but that
with all this downtime like you
performed you'd only eat so many pizza
really
you think is a good bed and some good
pillows over oh oh of course there's
lots to do but whatever those there's no
way you could argue with the front desk
but I have a good AC is lots to do but
if you're if that's your grind and been
your grind for years it's so easy to go
you know distract my mind with a few
pills
well the documentary is mostly done it's
going to go through one more phase of
you own other footage somebody holds the
footage I own all the footage that's
good yeah although it was reported in
this tabloid the blast about two weeks
ago that the footage is all gone yeah I
was reading that that's like but it was
after you already said you had the
footage and I was like wait she told me
she had a news I think it's the manager
welcome that was a court date I think it
was the manner because he had an
additional copy of the hard drives which
he believed were the only copy so he and
he refused to return them to this date
and claimed he lost to them so because I
was thinking any filmmaker would have
all between you and I who ever listened
to this podcast you know I might not get
booked or I guess all right we were
hanging out that club over there right
in Nashville and they were all crying
right they're all crying when I say no
names yeah man she was trying to keep
the dog what the [ __ ] do you care you're
dumb you're not married to this person
you you're nothing no there's no
bloodlines for you stop [ __ ] whining
and crying the doggy yeah they were in
bed whereas eating in Nashville and they
were all there they're all mad at me
we're all crying even she didn't she she
was trying to keep the dog like who who
who deserves a [ __ ] dog my children
actually right baby top row everybody
owns a stake in his life
you were there right IIIi got my juice
and I got my weed from them and I took
gonna hear a bunch of whiners there
Brian the dog was really sweet and my
kids wanted the dog but I gave it to the
guys who they there's an organization
they're like big paws that did all that
they got the dogs
licensed to be servicing animals these
guys when I went to Nashville the first
time one of them showed up at my house
and stayed with me for two nights helped
me clean out the storage unit help me do
like so much stuff help me break open
like our safe had run out of batteries
like he beat jackhammer I think this guy
was like he was like a god showing up to
help me and then a few months later
another guy from the same organization
flew to Nashville
I had keep in mind I had no money I gave
him my last thousand dollars cash rented
a Penske truck and this guy drove the
truck for me he I'll pack it up and
drove it across the country and help me
unpack it when it came to LA with the
stuff we wanted to keep from the house
those are the guys that got the dog and
that dog is a service animal what these
dumbasses in Nashville that helped
Ralphy get his drugs and want the dog
and they're crying the dog doesn't
belong to them and it and shouldn't
that's so funny there's four of my
anybody who party with you feel entitled
like even make it like a stray last
comment standing no phone calls II you
know why I'm frugal I sort of dig [ __ ]
you stepped on coconut water everybody
wants a little piece man I tell you what
if you die before me
none of these [ __ ] company or
funeral have people at the dorm I have
pictures I'm just saying if you die
before me that's what I aim for me I'm
gonna have that lady miss white [ __ ] you
first
Singham please do I might have to work
it please I would be honored for that
eating a corn
I want people have fun in my funeral but
I don't want I don't wanna
[ __ ] there I want people in your
past that I want to beat up I want
someone to die it look two of my fight
my prison the winner will keep something
they're looking for your Josh it might
be some drugs in a moment when I'm when
you want a Ralphie passed away and then
you're going through the boys oh man
someone who's almost bad stuff written
about you know I read one and I said it
suggested paid you Walter divorce and
then and then Ralphie passed away and
then and then against one of the right
one of the people in the bottom whatever
comment one ear off with drug dealers
what's that I got she was she got
everything well some you know I would
have liked him to live and had child
support that would have been the better
route for as far as the divorce no catch
with the kids you know I don't I don't
understand why anybody look I was with
him for 17 years the last couple of
years of his life he was really sick and
we all know how it ended so anybody who
says I just I recognized that they're
sick and and some of those oh my god
what the guy where Ralphie died at his
house he tried to keep his car like
crazy stuff can opener man yeah but he
kept his cry the flood he helped a lot
of people out too though Ralphie helped
everyone I met people that come up to me
at school you know Ralphie may really
help me his nephew bro together that
works for the news so much ACOG oh those
are a guy he came out and he said that
yeah man rough for me oh no it's down in
the south it was a college who did I did
a college in now and Alabama no no it
was a kid there he said that roughly may
help them a lot and then met another guy
that said like yeah and then like I mean
I mean I mean waiter than it's a man
roster maybe they want to get a give me
cash you had none of these [ __ ]
waiters coming ever tip me who you and
then turn em in you Joey Ralphie are the
only one that took care of me Ralphie
way in a way like too generous because
like if I open there was like like if I
open it will give him a sad story
there's a lot of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
wrongful or low
we're doing nothing yeah no no he was
really smash brothers bottom teeth they
were carnival workers before people do
their battle Ralphie boy in the end but
a lot of common gay bro find out that
somebody with a sad story and then and
it's like you have that disposable cash
so it's like you know just a couple
licks whatever it's not gonna bug but
people take advantage yeah tell me you
know here's the crazy thing
Oh Rafi just booked bad choice in my
pocket at the airport it's so rude
because wrong no no but not only that
but like for 17 years of him doing that
he and I were together like if we go out
to dinner it's a very sexist royal if
people if you go out to dinner together
and somebody puts a cheque down and he
takes the check I was like thanks
Ralphie thanks Ralphie but the truth is
is Ralphie I were we worked together for
years so like I always whatever but as
soon as [ __ ] hit the fan all of those
people Smash Brothers Chad came to me
crying he was literally bawling you know
big ass job at the bald head
intimidating [ __ ] crying and he
says I'm living in a shack behind my
uncle's brothers he was I don't know but
this was his story was that he was
living in a shack and he was crying
because he had just split up with his
wife and he needed work desperately and
I said look I'll I'll get you out on the
road with broth but there's two of you
so it's gonna cost like a lot more so
it's just gonna be the feature money for
the two of you and you'll have to share
a hotel room can you deal with that he
was like yeah see I see I think you
think you think he's like wiping tears
away and then now and now I got him the
gig and then when things went bad he was
literally trash tagging horrible stuff
about me online and I'm like chugging oh
I miss you I get to my house like I
never did one thing to any of them ever
not one of them in Gabe in in Vegas when
Roth died I call
I'm like I'm I hadn't talked to him in 3
years because you know when divorce is
having people split up and go with
friend friends but then I said go to the
cash shake go with the cash but I
figured things would settle right I
figured eventually it all simmer down
and then we'll all be friends again
because that's what happens bad blood
eventually goes good again right so I'm
not gonna Roth can have them for now and
we'll worry about it later but when he
passed I called up Gabe and I was like
well you got to live my nightmare
because I always thought it would be me
to find him and I'm so sorry for you
this really sucks
and then and we caught into conversating
and I said look the memorial is gonna be
on this particular day and when you come
out just what did he like I've been
assuming had a suitcase or whatever I'm
sure you want to get that cooler house
so just like I he stayed with yeah sad
and I was like whatever you want like
what who wants to if somebody died in my
house I'd be like kick the [ __ ] out of
here you go
so the memorial and right before the
memorial then I called him again I said
listen this might not seem important to
you but if there's like his Cologne or
something like that is in the bathroom
make sure to keep that cuz August wants
his daddy smell so he shows up at the
memorial with a baggie and he hands me
the Cologne I was like oh my God thank
you so much for remembering that means
so much to me
I guess the suitcase is in your car we
can transfer it and he goes no I didn't
bring it and I was like oh okay don't
worry about it I think roughly my
suitcase it's okay Seiko don't worry
about it the guy whose house you died in
I don't worry about it I'll I'll get it
from you whenever the time is right it's
cool like this isn't my concern the next
day I fly to Nashville and I get off the
airplane get to my house and I I look
for the car and I'm like where's the car
because it was a Denali
it was our tour vehicle nope I can't
find I call the lot where the bus used
to be and I was like do you have my car
no and I can't find it I'm calling
calling calling I get a tip-off from
somebody that it's at Gabe's house and
so I start texting him and you won't get
back to me and so then I call my
attorney I'm like I think my car is at
this man's house so then hit my attorney
calls another attorney who calls Gabe
office and gave text me I do have the
car so I call him I said um I need the
car because my car that I was driving in
LA was the only thing that wasn't locked
in probate I had zero cash I had to sell
my vehicle so I had enough money to feed
buy groceries literally no money and I
need that car so that I have something
to get around town in when are you gonna
bring it out because Rafi's brother flew
to Vegas to pick up his ashes with his
nephew and his
stepsister any one of them could have
driven it out you could have driven it
out
I need the car and he goes well this was
back in October maybe the end of
November December and I'm like [ __ ]
you're not gonna give me back my card
like you were stealing me like this is
crazy so that weekend I flew home got on
air put the kids in sleep over woke up
at like 4:00 a.m. the next morning flew
to Vegas for police officers met me in a
gas station escorted me to his house
they knock on his door with their stick
and I and he doesn't come to the door so
I have that extra set of keys I put on
the car alarm in the garage he turns off
the car alarm they're knocking I turn on
the car alarm he turns off the car alarm
the third time he comes down hidden
gives me the car in the suitcase and I
drive back off through the desert fog
these dudes are this is where he died
this is one of his friends and you know
what I don't I knew where that piece of
[ __ ] never Bookman well that's over oh
yeah yeah the dirty show which I don't I
mean look here's the thing
Gabe and I were friends like I have no
gripe with Gabe look he's a mold
inspector this was his greatest moment
in holders I think so I think that's his
day gig I don't think it's a problem how
can mold inspector I honestly wish him
on I've been a lot of therapy so I wish
about the guy I wish him the best we
don't know you know what look you know
here's the thing that was his greatest
moment in life right is comedy like it
was opening for out he got to do things
that he never would have gotten to do it
wasn't for Rafi we're students and get
on stage but like come on do you don't
do that like I'm no matter how bad you
think I am as a human being I'm still a
single mother I'm a single mother with
two young kids in my like Rafi just
passed away give me back my [ __ ] car
like what that what are you gonna do
strip it you don't have the title like
oh I guess he'd sell for 500 bucks a
modem I'm a crazy man you know people
people on the outside though they always
think they know like I'd seen honestly
I'd seen comments that you know gold
digger all this stuff who gold digs
after 17 years that like people say that
about me when you would post pictures of
us on your facebook usually because they
just didn't know
who I was and they would think that I'm
only with you for the money like they
didn't realize I was with you and you
you know watches all in your in your
cabinets and everything and like you
know you took my last $10 of gas money
for drugs and wasn't like those things
like those little things we don't know
as gold diggers don't stick around but I
would still get that that phrase through
I get it all the car they own a piece of
you I'm gonna say like most of these
guys but hey the rugged fat bro they
were getting fed right other southern
brother their milk is gone oh yeah
running running little babies like what
a piece of us lost too you know
yeah they want a little piece I can't be
havin oh wait for my wallet
how about all the tribute shows that
happen oh my god it was what it was
wonder South there was one someone in
Nashville oh my god the one in Nashville
so there then boom boom so I had to go
to court that week and Nashville they
ran to tribute shows did Ralphie
while they simultaneously are suing the
estate I had to go to court that week in
Nashville while they were making money
off of Rafah so basically they're suing
Ralphie the copy show no name what were
they swing him oh it's like the the its
probate it's this like so if you go back
and he owe them or something no I I
don't look I there's two one more case
pending and no because no they're saying
that he he owed them something I'd say
I'm trying to okay so future dates or
something okay no so the managers can't
claiming that he's owed back commissions
he also claimed that he never gotten
paid which is [ __ ] I found checks
that he gotten paid but he's claiming
back commissions but Ralphie had a
different corporations so the
corporation that he had it that's
there's no money in the corporation so
even if even if it's justified but
here's the thing ruffies dead you're
still suing Ralphie like and you're
doing Rafi's children so and then you're
throwing a so even if it is justified
which I don't think it is okay but even
if it is you're suing him while running
a tribute show with his name making
money off of him and he's dead while his
children are still alive it's just like
it blows my mind like if it's me it
doesn't matter if it was ten dollars a
thousand dollars fifty thousand dollars
I don't want any part of this you go
about your life and we we had a good run
you know what I'm saying but like
there's it's not worth it there's not
enough money in the world that would
make it worth it for me to sue somebody
who's dead
yeah it's it sucks that's my thoughts on
look you're thinking about how much
money be worth to see somebody who's
dead how much money oh I don't know I
just I it's it's been a crazy ride it's
been really interesting I've learned a
lot and I try and stay it's kind of been
interesting because they Deezy the
documentary like anybody who thought
that I didn't have Ralphie's best
intentions at heart I I was so adamant
that he get sober and that's so obvious
in this project so and the one-hour
special is such a gift for Ralphie
because he was so goddamn talented and
funny and I want him to have one more
special plus it helps keep the kids in
their home and in their school so
actually I remember man like calm I will
say like were there four years ago five
before I got married and it did your
your your ten podcast right
we're still running that I'm keeping it
going you come back and then you and I
we were talking about that when you
first told me I didn't know that you and
I were talking in the parking lot how
about Ralphie right after the show was
gonna one-on-one and then you really
broke down and they were talking about
that conversation I mean I totally saw
when Ralphie I cried you did yeah you
were very sad I remember like I wish I
could have done something you know but
there's nothing he could do you know and
you can you have told me you know that
it was sad because he didn't those pills
chewing on oh man and I'm all the time
fighting on the internet and then no she
was saying also that he was there in the
house without know yeah
it's just so removed from everybody he
would come from like reading on the
robot sixteen weeks and then like be at
home on the ecology but not really
interacting yeah yeah I mean to be his
size alone never mind
the prescriptions and and other
substances just to being physically that
size to try and move that weight around
art every day oh my god everything he
felt was love you right it fell all the
time no Josie felt once there was at one
time I don't know it really happened but
Jesus told me the story but um somebody
said that somebody gave mom or maybe
there was I was a lie someone made up to
cover up the oxy story he said that
somebody showed up and gave her a rough
email is humongous true but you well
that was a whole big long that he I
don't think it was computer cuz here we
go half a loaf in the next day throw on
stage the same night I'm first I wasn't
with him there but um that was when
things were pretty rough um but he
definitely III don't know what was in
his bloodstream but I mean I can't
imagine was just she but that she [ __ ]
those are strong too yeah here's a big
one though I got a giant sign at the
side of the bottle water
yeah I'm sure I'm sure yeah he was
messed up and yeah I think there was
it's just sad yeah he used to get stuff
from everybody he there was one guy it's
interesting there was this one guy Nick
you can go on his Facebook page this guy
Nick came at me on Ralphie's Facebook
page because when I'd launched there's
been a couple people who the gold digger
people are the people who are mad at me
believe me for his passing right now
until they realized that's [ __ ] but
anyways he wrote me a message on on
Ralphie's wall that like commenting that
wasn't very nice and I just took the
high road and I just said Nick I hope
you liked the special when it comes out
that kind of thing but this is the same
man that was friends with Ralphie who
had sent a bottle of pills through the
mail to him and I only know that because
there was a package that came and I
didn't know what it was but you know
somebody opens a package and he heard
the rubbish in the trash and then Ralph
flew to Tennessee
the next day when the assistant came and
picked him up he drove him directly to
hospital because he couldn't stand up he
was like falling over and I wouldn't we
tried to figure it was in his system so
I dug through the trash and then located
the same guy and I found him and called
him and said what was in there and he
said it was oxycodone and some other
stuff and so that force and his
attacking me on Facebook for trying to
launch an IndieGoGo campaign to create
his one-hour special and I didn't write
him back on Facebook cuz I feel like
Facebook he probably has friends family
his work or whatever but I almost it
took me all the control the world not to
go do you remember the time you shipped
in Mexico town in the mail maybe you
should be coming after me so I guess I'm
kind of blasting him on here right now
but it's a lot of work to do your
friends off oh yeah so me like doctor
the mechanic bro I'm an impact you for
parties your attorney it was trying to
give get one on me dawg
well that one kid who you partied with
for days around New Year's little guy
you called Al Pacino you called Scarface
all the time no he was like 1890
he's a kid but then they came with you
know Ventura yeah I knew I knew why you
invited them you know that watching the
car but you had a contract so you had to
be on stage and you were messed up for
days and before that so I was like you
got to get it together and make it up
there so I think I took you up there
they drove behind in their car because
they're following him with drugs like I
know I knew where they were I mean he's
invited a reason they were like man we
can't go together by Caravan oh yeah he
said we can't go together cuz basically
I'm the bad person I'm the mom trying to
make him get to his job you know making
sure he does his thing right so I felt
like a bad guy there cuz I'm on the buzz
killington here but he had to make his
gig you had no money we had no you we
were living check to check at that point
you were not headlining everywhere like
you are now and
so this was very important that you make
this show and so you did it and then
we're back at that stupid buffet line
cuz it was the one of those nights where
they had rice and beans and food Mexican
food right at the club and that guy New
Year's Day bro New Year's Day that guy's
there next to me that the little kid
drug deal okay not even drug dealing he
just had the stuff he was the party
supplier so we're standing there and
we're standing there piling up our plate
and I said you know he is not gonna want
to hang out with you when he starts
getting sober he's like what yeah but I
said if you I said if he dies at your
house I'm taking the cops right to your
front door that you're the one you're
the one where he died he said Philippe
is a big boy I think he could make his
own decisions I said alright
[ __ ] and then he stayed away
from me the rest of the night he was all
scared and then he was like call me
ma'am the rest that night like he was
all scared but the [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
they don't care none of them care I get
I told that thing with that guy that
white guy Charles down down downtown - I
said you're [ __ ] white trash and then
that guy didn't understand why you
didn't call him after everything was
after your ass over either used to party
with that dude but I knew where he where
he was - and I was like I knew you were
hanging out of it there and you had to
make that taping that gene pompa show
right the big show and that was like
more money than we had made in months
and I said look he has to work or he's
gonna lose a lot of money and make a
bunch of people mad everybody's calling
me where is where is he where is he and
I knew where you were and I said I see
every bit of policy the shoes bro
everybody's ready to do this show and
then you showed up somehow killed it for
two shows in a row and then I came down
there a mess I was such a mess I hadn't
eaten and I think two days after the
shabba-doo fell dirty bro I got down
there and I
now to to showers my left or sweating
alcohol and drugs I was doing you know I
had one beer I'm so tired of worried
about what the [ __ ] that was yeah she
finally collapse I had one beer and I
passed out like somebody roofied me cuz
I had finally like was able to relax I
knew where he was I knew he wasn't dead
in a gutter somewhere
and I and I had I had no food in myself
lingers were singing around and I think
I told you in Chicago
didn't I point you thank you for them
didn't I boy didn't I point them out to
you in Chicago and I said those pieces
of [ __ ] right there they're his
suppliers the Hardy Boys yeah that's the
Hardy Boys wonder twin powers check this
[ __ ] out
so I did the whole the mad little swoop
already brother hello to be like this
broad whatever like you poured water on
yourself that night yeah yeah after that
sweaty bro did that [ __ ] ever earful
know how Dean said that they're the
producers were holding it on the shelf
for something I don't maybe he owes the
money I don't know special
yeah that would have been a good show
what's up pool where can they find that
in funding for the documentary so it's
on indiegogo you can go to my follow me
on social media cuz I'm linking up on
that on Facebook or also Ralphie's it's
still very active his Facebook is
Twitter is Instagram I'm posting on
there so you can follow but just go to
indiegogo.com and type in Rafi mayor
Lana Turner and then also I haven't
one--at my one-hour special just came in
oh [ __ ] at least no no not that it's
actually so I wrote a song that I've
done I have like all this content out
but that just came back out on to be TV
which is this new free app which is
really cool and then also I relaunched
perfect-10 podcast so since everybody
here loves podcasts oh yeah over to that
it's just what's your social media just
my name just lah you gotta remember the
H na Turner tu RN ER so you can find we
have most of them here right though
Karen Karen runs house key oh I love
Karen ever ago where'd you meet her at I
met her when I first started stand-up in
Texas
she started in Houston Babbitt bobert
that way that was once winter broke
though have you met in every every time
I meet a new there's a Babbitt like that
works in every kind of Babich with an
agency yeah but that type of person that
sort of like becomes king [ __ ] a turd
island and treats everybody really bad
and then they end up in an insurance job
because they're just like you know but
then everybody kids as their ass for the
time when they're in that position yeah
well like a Babbitt mark Babbitt he had
Wild West comedy tours and he's to book
all those but he shows back in the day
he book Ralph or back in the days no he
never really was into Ralph we booked he
booked like I'm Gabriel frame Soto and
then I'm he hooked up with inner Conner
the molasses Joe my last part more lives
I know Babbitt was really nice to me
when I first started he this is a fun
Easter because the first time I ever did
comedy
like I paid was from babbit like I was
two months in after my first open mic
and he let me do a set on the main stage
there and I walked offstage and he put
twenty dollars in my hand and I didn't
know what it was for and he goes I just
paid you for your spot and I at that
moment I was like I'm gonna be a comic
cuz nobody had ever paid me to ever
stand on stage before and I still make
basically twenty bucks but I was just
like oh my god this is amazing so I owe
a lot to him because he started he
really was the first person that ever
like was like you can do this even
though I know he's like every that story
of that same person who's it's it's
always a weird thing right and here in
LA where did you start accomplished or
laugh at you at first a lot of spots at
the Laugh Factory
whatever tweet robin jesus nada
Jamie was always sad well he could have
managed the more you do to that level
you know what Jamie was good too rough
really really good to Ralph and really
really good to me I will never speak in
a word about Jamie and I haven't worked
that Club since Ralphie got kicked out
when Ralphie got kicked out I got kicked
out too and Jamie over the years has
said that I could come back but whenever
I start calling again I don't really get
spots they're very much better it's a
bad word because he left him when and
then actually I heard another story from
Jamie only maybe a year ago me money
that's what Jamie said always and I sued
him I didn't even know that Jamie felt
like Ralph had owed him money so I I was
surprised I said nobody I've never seen
an invoice or a bill or anything so if
there was money owed I wish I'd have
known like that was years ago
and that was that so an engagement party
blip of that fact right and Jamie was a
like I said I can't find a bad word to
say about Jamie because he was always
and you know here's the thing our
business it sucks because we're a human
commodity right so like if you're
dealing with Coke or Pepsi and then you
leave Coke for Pepsi like that's that
you're done like it's just a product but
we're a product so when the product
leaves you and goes to somebody else and
makes them a lot of money people get
pissed they want to like they're like
death to you and death to your firstborn
I can't tell you how many people that's
happened every time he switched
management or switched at whatever
the hate that came from him and then
also like like I said I don't get spots
there anymore I'd love to get back up
there it's like my favorite I think now
he's so removed from the booking process
- I don't even know it's like oh yeah
geez cool I've always been friends
friendly I don't know I just it's weird
I I don't know I get plenty of spots
right now and it doesn't have to be at
the factory I'd love to get back up
there cuz it's easy but you know I like
it cuz I do a lot of shitty hard spots
yeah and that's why I'm [ __ ] real
strong right now
it's cuz I've been doing these [ __ ]
spots for years nudist gigs I'll do
whatever memories of you and Ralphie was
dumb but when Dublin was around and
Tuesday nights it was Halloween and I
had me and Marty Moreno G Riley and this
kind is all coming him Noah and Marty
Miranda we walked from the Laugh Factory
to the [ __ ] West Hollywood for the
parade Rafi - we run into you and him at
the Dublin oh yeah was dressed like he
would you like a big like a super baby
yet the costume as a superhero or the
superhero yeah with a Matthew just up to
I think I was just as a superhero as
well like his side can't go I think I
was like his snack like his side snack
kit or something like yeah he was supper
man and I was your supper man yeah he
was that that's why people always
thought I was a gold digger though he
bean after he started making money right
but when I started making money and he
got famous people just assumed that I
was because what I'm a crazy I'm crazy
because I was with a broke fat not just
fat a gigantic Lee fat-fuck I mean like
it doesn't make sense so they assumed
the worst but like how could she be that
and I look back and I go what the [ __ ]
was I thinking - because my mother hated
him and she knew that this wasn't gonna
end well like because now I'm like I'm a
mother and if my daughter was doing what
I was doing back then I'd be like what I
got a wrong with you oh yeah so but I
can see why people look at it looked at
us and thought that at times because
they don't know me and they didn't know
that I and they don't know him they
didn't know how special he was so how's
the baby so how are they taking it good
you know
it's hard because I've been very
proactive with them they're in therapy
they went to a bereavement camp this
summer every kid at the camp has lost a
parent or sibling in the last three
years my daughter goes to group how how
la is that I got my daughter in group um
my son is a little bit different than
her and how he's right he's younger and
if you remember I said Rafi had the
public pulmonary embolisms yours before
so Roth checked out on August when he
was about 18 months old and so August
really didn't have the experience of
having a father being active with him at
all his entire childhood and then he
died so it's a really big betrayal but
we're working through it you a little
Dewayne oh yeah this one you're younger
but you know boys mature a little more
slowly when it comes to that sort of
thing he's angry ready he also you know
he's got a little temper and he's got
little he's and he's funny so you know
I'm [ __ ] them up sufficiently to be
funny through all of this at least
they've got a good sense of humor but I
don't know I mean they're they're really
good people and I don't know what it's
like to lose your father because I I'm
lucky my dad's still alive and I talk to
my parents every week just about it
sometimes a couple of times we can
they've been so supportive that I just
think about how what I'm gonna do when I
mean I can't even imagine losing my
father and I'm a I'm a woman I just
that's just beyond me so I feel further
lose a father but know that I have a
father who was in there
emotionally I think that Kimmy we must
work yes that's worse I think I think
that's worse I mean that as a kid I mean
I lost my dad twice because he left when
I was eight and then he died last year
but but yeah so but as a boy I think
it's tougher because you don't have like
you said he didn't have him this whole
time so maybe he was always hoping that
at one point they would have this bond
and then he never got to have
davus yeah and it was it was really hard
to watch like especially towards the
last year year and a half of Rafi's life
because that the no-shows he couldn't so
I had to get orders in place that was a
really big deal and it was it really
sucked but the judge puts orders so it's
very clear what you can and can't do
because up until he's able to get orders
it was really loose and it was really
really really hard to figure out what
was gonna happen because there was no
there's nothing concrete especially
dealing with Ralphie's so he I was
required one day a week to call him
that's it and he he couldn't even get on
the phone and then the visitations he
would come to LA he would be here and
we'd be waiting for him to show up for
his visits and he just wouldn't show up
or I would send the kids to meet him
like at the Grove or wherever and he
wouldn't show up and so the kids would
come home and be like so disappointed
because then they think something's
wrong with them right he's like even
though they understand oh no it's not
you it's not either that how do you fix
that for a child so yeah that's it's
[ __ ] up but a bit Rafi and I always
have to defend Rafi because he loved his
kids yeah who did he loved them so much
and and I know that he wanted the best
for them always it just the person got
lost in the substances and then sad it's
not an uncommon story so waka waka what
you got as far as what anything to add
cover dog thank you very much for
letting sharing your side of the story
now I'm doing Albuquerque at the end of
the month we're at um the vault
the vault and then I'm doing Kansas City
in like two months I'm easing my way
back out on the road because it's hard
to leave the babies and such but I'm
doing Kansas City in like 8 or 10 weeks
and there's I'm headlining two of the
nights I'm bumping down to feature but I
need to work yeah we'll do it on
Instagram just my name lah na tu RN ER
and one more time working at people
submit I always say I like to say it's
not a donation as much as it is like
being a part of something because I
think of donation is like if I'm gonna
donate to something it's gonna be for
some like kid that's dying and needs my
help but I said this isn't that this is
like you can be part of something cool
and get something cool if you go to the
IndieGoGo page there's some per digital
downloads there's t-shirts there's even
his jackets I have two of his leather
jackets for if there's any big fat boys
that have money we got it they're like 5
grand but that's what they cost to make
and then I actually put his orange
jacket up there it's a joke I put it up
for like 50 grand but Saudi wants that
they can have the one in the photo and
the orange jacket I just said I just put
it up there some people talk about it
but um but if somebody wants it they can
have it it's just like stupid money but
the other jackets are actually really
like that's what they would cost and
then and so yeah so it's not so much a
contribution is a participation in
something really cool and then and then
you can even get your name in the
credits or you could have an associate
producers credit that's expensive but
that's somebody bought one of those so
yeah so be a part of it you can you can
watch it in a few months when it comes
out and go I hope to make that so oh
yeah yeah okay thanks guys
what's up fool shut up - Lana Turner and
Rodrigo to check out yeah my podcast
yeah what's your pocket name again
perfect ten perfect and check me out on
that podcast - we shot it on to a tunnel
we were on our subway that was fun Lisa
what was your pod kill you started you
park it was I'm going to I'm going to
good I have to get it time but there she
goes no we called girls school but
thank you